poetic naturalism is a combination of
two things naturalism and poetic myths
okay so naturalism is an old idea it's
basically the idea that the universe all
of reality is just one thing it's the
natural world there's no separate
supernatural world it's just the stuff
that we know about obeying the laws of
nature whatever they may be laws that we
can discover by doing science
the poetic part says that even though
there's only one world the natural world
there are many ways of talking about
that world so sometimes we want to be
particle physicists right if we want to
talk about electrons and protons obeying
Schrodinger's equation of quantum
mechanics other times you want to be
biologists right we talk about organisms
and evolution and so forth other times
you want to be human being so you want
to talk about values and we want to talk
about why we act in certain ways rather
than other ways and these all need to
fit together
that's the poetic part of it that
there's different stories we can tell
about the universe some of which are
just science stories but some of which
are very human stories I think that our
natural human way of talking about the
world is multifaceted by its very nature
right we talk about stuff doing things
you know the scientific part of the
world we talk about the human part of
the world morals values meaningfulness
and stuff like that and there is a
temptation let me say when you become
more knowledgeable about the scientific
size of things to eliminate the other
side of things there's an indeed there's
a whole idea called eliminative ism
where you take something like morality
or consciousness and say it doesn't
exist right I think that's a mistake
because it's not that it doesn't exist
it's that it's explained by an emergent
from these other layers these other ways
are talking about reality so it's it's
somewhere poetic naturalism is somewhere
in between it's in between a view that
says there are many different aspects to
reality they're fundamentally different
from each other and a view that says
there's only one reality we should only
ever do science this is saying there's
only one reality but there's many ways
of talking about that reality that map
on to the different ways we have of
thinking about
you know I'm a physicist so I think
about the most fundamental layer of
reality and physicists can get a little
cocky in thinking about the world right
physics is hard there's a lot of math
involved and we tend to think that if
you can do physics you can do anything
you can figure out any problem
I've always been resistant to that
temptation but nevertheless I would
sometimes give in to it so when I was
young I thought like many physicists
still think that you could sort of
derive morality or meaningfulness from
the fundamental laws of nature and then
by becoming better trained in philosophy
I realized I wasn't really true that I
was cheating my way to the answer to the
problem but I didn't want to give up
entirely and so I think that the happy
meeting ground is accepting that some
choices that we make about the world
about how to talk about the world are
human choices or choices that are up to
us they're not fixed by the universe
what we decide right versus wrong is not
something that we go out and measure
experimentally right so I don't think it
was any one discovery or one piece of
scientific advance I just think it's a
it's a nice reconciliation between what
we know about science and what we know
about philosophy you know time is one of
the most obvious important things about
the universe that we know about right
there's space where things are located
and there's time that flows on and all
this stuff around us in the universe
happens over and over again and that's
time one of the things that is most
obvious about time is it the past and
future are different right we think if
the past is fixed it's in the book
that's already happened the future is up
for grabs right we can make choices
about what had happened in a few
it wasn't until long after philosophy
and science began that we realized that
the laws of physics from Isaac Newton to
the present day don't distinguish
between the past and future they treat
them exactly the same so why is it that
our everyday lives have past and future
being very very different that's the
arrow of time problem and we basically
know the answer it has to do with
entropy this idea of disorderliness of a
physical system systems tend to start
out very orderly and become more
disorderly over time there's a whole
long discussion to have about why that
helps us remember the past and not the
future and so forth but cosmologists
people who study the universe as a whole
would like to understand why the
universe began with such low entropy
near the Big Bang our universe was
remarkably orderly compared to how messy
it could have been and that set the
stage for all the differences between
past and future for the last 14 billion
years but we don't know what it was that
set the stage in exactly that way I
think the broadly speaking cosmology is
a subset of physics you know physics
will study both the very small and the
very large cosmology studies the whole
universe all at once
most of physics takes the universe apart
and looks at it piece by piece
but here's a very very very nice thing
when you look at the universe in really
tiny pieces
it becomes simpler right an electron is
far simpler than a frog or sheep or a
constitutional government but when the
look of the universe on the largest
scale at the earliest times it also
looks simpler again so the universe
looks complicated in between the scales
on human size scales or you know between
a millimeter and a Lightyear that's
where the universe looks complicated but
there's this fundamental simplicity that
you get in the very small and the very
large the very very early and the very
late to the universe I've had a great
time I love the idea of bringing
together philosophy and science and all
sorts of other ideas right I think that
we artificially put up barriers between
these in academia especially there's no
reason why those barriers need to be
preserved when we go
more public kind of event you know I
think that it's largely what I expected
or maybe what I hoped for let's put it
that way but you know as I was saying
this morning in my first event early in
the morning on a drizzly English morning
Saturday people waking up and coming
through the countryside to talk about
cosmology in the beginning of the
universe and that just warms my heart
that just makes me feel really good
about qunit humanity generally
how will I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your ticket now but how the light
gets in dog